we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're going to the 7 3 to area code next
who's this calling from 7 3 2 hey David
it's Kyle can you hear me
I can hear you Kyle go ahead hey um so
just kind of a more philosophical
question about progressivism in general
are there any like major progressive
political points that you don't agree
with or have any issues with that I
don't agree with or that I do have
issues with you mean right yeah it's all
about matters of degree Kyle so I'm I'm
increasingly against so-called litmus
tests on principles I think that listen
I just read about a guy who's running as
a Democrat who is against abortion and
and like for something else that just
really has no place sort of on the left
so this stuff matters and specific
policy positions matter and principles
matter but I think we need to take a
sort of more holistic approach there's
no one there's no set of principles that
will always be applied in the same way
that makes it so that we can say hey
here's an issue on which I just disagree
with progressives I mean I've been very
clear that I am against the sort of safe
space language policing that has become
popular in some areas of the left I've
talked about how I I think that the way
identity politics has been carried out
by the left over the last five to eight
or maybe even 10 years has probably done
more of a disservice than a service to
the left so there's there's
disagreements on implementation but if
you're asking me is there like a broad
strokes principle of the progressive
platform that I just flat-out disagree
with it it's it's not so black and white
you know no I understand I mean I find
myself having issues with the
progressive ideology on education in
terms of both higher ed and lower levels
of education I'm personally more for you
know implementing charters
in urban areas if possible and I'm not
really sure about you know free college
for everyone so I feel like that's one
place where even though most of my other
politics are progressive that's a whole
area where I'd probably disagree with
the majority progressives on so I was
neither well all bare issues big issues
that we were not gonna be able to get
into today but thanks for calling in and
letting me know I think it's interesting
it's important to sort of think about
there's really no one movement that I
think is likely to encompass everybody's
exact views and and that's sort of okay
that that's sort of how the world works
thanks to everybody who called in let's
take a quick break and we'll be back
with more right after this